boris johnson is on his way out as
british prime minister it is clearly now
the will
of the parliamentary conservative party
that there should be a new leader of
that party and therefore a new prime
minister boris johnson's resignation
leaves the conservative party in
disarray and undergoing a leadership
contest
what happens now and what challenges
will the new prime minister face
observers thought britain's decision to
leave the european union and then boris
johnson's elevation as prime minister
was part of a wave of populism that was
sweeping the west the question for
britain now is whether that wave
continues or whether the tide goes back
out in the united states the republican
party has decided to double down on the
legacy of donald trump uh echoing many
of his distortions and his disregard for
america's constitutional norms the
evidence in britain is the past few days
is the conservative party has found its
limit and it wants to turn back it has
looked over the precipice and decided it
doesn't want to jump but uh its own bout
of uh introspection is a design decides
what sort of party it wants to be
uh really is is masking the really quite
significant challenges the united
kingdom faces
the british economy is going through a
severe period of stress uh inflation is
predicted to
reach 11
in the autumn uh that's being driven in
large part by energy costs which are
going to be landing families with with
large energy bills in the autumn public
services are under severe strain in part
due to years of tight budgets but also a
huge backlog of work that they're trying
to crunch through
as a result of covid which put hospital
appointments and
court cases on pause for years the
conservative party has warned that its
opponents would return britain to the
the days of the 1970s when britain was
stricken with strikes the truth is boris
johnson leaves office with uh
significant waves of industrial action
uh the railway workers were on strike
not so long ago now see strikes amongst
barristers
threatened strikes amongst teachers
amongst other public servants if we're
now facing a summer with a caretaker
government and a contest for a new
leader one of the questions that's going
to have to be resolved is uh to what
extent can public pay be increased
without further stoking inflation
britain has been uh vigorous certainly
not alone in the world of course but
vigorous in supplying ukraine with uh
both weapons and money but also a form
of moral support in helping to amplify
his case that this is a fight for
the conservative party uh let alone
within british politics than the british
public itself so i think in any concept
of party leadership contest you are
going to see every single candidate
reaffirm their support for ukraine in
the ukrainian struggle and
there will almost certainly be a contest
over who can pledge the most money for
britain's armed forces
boris johnson was the leading light of
the campaign to get britain out of the
european union in 2016. he came to
office in 2019 on a pledge to get brexit
done to deliver the divorce that theresa
may could not and he has failed the
united kingdom has left the eu but the
the question of northern ireland uh and
that the common border that the united
kingdom and the republic of ireland
share has not been addressed now just
before he was leaving office he unveiled
a new plan under which the united
kingdom would unilaterally renounce the
the the protocol on northern ireland
which put arrangements in place to to
address that the new leader faces a
choice do they push on with that plan
which will um toxify relations with the
european union and amount to a breach of
international law or do they return to
diplomacy and trying to find an agreed
solution
boris johnson came to power pledging to
restore britain's place in the world and
end the humiliation that was the theresa
may period when the deadlock over brexit
and her miserable exit from office
really made britain uh the butt of jokes
in european capitals on that measure he
has failed uh once again a prime
conservative prime minister leaves
office in uh
less than three years on the clock uh
dragged out by their own colleagues
paralysis in government
one of the challenges facing a success
is whether they can
restore britain to the quiet competence
that it was known for in its public
administration and diplomacy or whether
the pratfalls of the johnson era are
destined to continue
to follow all our coverage on boris
johnson's departure click the link thank
you for watching and don't forget to
subscribe
you